we have a guest that just joined us here
uh Congressman U.S representative Scott
Perry from Pennsylvania's tent District
he's a retired Pennsylvania Army
National Guard Brigadier General who
just recently the FBI came up to him and
asked him for his phone and we'd like
them to share that experience with us so
uh uh Scott Perry thank you for being a
guest here on the podcast
well thanks so much I sure appreciate it
um look it's not something you aspire to
uh we get uh one month of the year that
we can kind of plan to be with our
family some of it and that month is
August so uh my family it's expensive
but we so we all pitch in and we rent a
little house down at the beach at the
shore down at the Jersey Shore and uh we
spend you know time with the with the
kids with their grandparents and their
uncles and aunts and those type of
things and of course you don't expect a
knock on the door at nine o'clock on the
in the morning at the shore house
um because you you know you're you're
not you're there with people you know
and people that know you don't knock on
the they just come in so I answered the
door and of course I'm greeted with
three by three guys in suits at the
beach which is kind of out of character
so they say good morning Congressman
we're here to take your phone I just
happened to have the phone in my hand
and I said you know I put it in my
pocket and I said you know I'm not
giving you anything uh until you you
know you prove that you have the
authority to do that and of course you
know look I look through the paperwork
uh I look through their Badges and so on
and so forth and you know I started
asking me questions and look I'm a guy
who grew up revering the FBI the CIA
people in uniform so this is so out of
character but of course I yeah I'm
living in the world of today in America
so when they started asking me questions
politely I said look I got nothing to
say to you people
um and so you know we went through the
the process they gave me a receipt tell
me they're bringing it back you know
today when they're done uh taking an
image of it and uh and they said you
have any questions for me and I said
yeah I got a question for you how did
you find me here
of course I know how they found me
they're they're holding in their hands
now how they found me there but I wanted
them to say it uh and and the gentleman
kind of got a smirk on his face and he
said it's just what we do
and he said we'll contact you when uh
when we're ready to you know give your
phone back and I said well I don't have
a phone to contact me so can you call my
chief of staff and let her know so she
can let me know
you know call my wife or what have you
but I didn't look what I didn't want to
have happen was have the FBI knock on
the door and have my elderly you know in
their 80s father-in-law and
mother-in-law have to go to the door and
deal with that it's just not it's not
appropriate and uh and and they said
well what's her number I said well I
don't know it's in my phone
and the guy says to me well it's not
like we're going to go rifling through
your phone like you got to be kidding me
uh I said look I don't give you
authorization to do anything but I give
you authorization to get my number from
my chief of staff out of my phone hours
and hours later
my father-in-law is calling my my wife
we're down at the beach with my kids
uh and um and he says the FBI is here so
oh great you know so I pack up you know
look I'm a typical dad at the beach I
got a card with all the kids toys the
blanket The Umbrellas all that's chairs
all that stuff right and pack it up like
a packed meal I send my kids back to the
house uh and you know I start heading up
the street you know what I'm looking for
not hard to find it to Shore black SUV
parked on the side street
I stopped pushing my cart I walk over
towards the towards the vehicle of
course all these guys jump out walk up
to me paperwork my phone I said to the
gentleman I said sir why could you not
honor your commitment he said what
commitment was that I said the
commitment you made to call my chief of
staff instead of bothering my my
father-in-law and my mother-in-law he
said well we couldn't find her
oh come on
I thought that's what you do you know so
that that was my experience you know
they took an image of the phone and I'm
sure look I'm sure they they're trying
to do the paperwork to say they want to
look inside the phone at this point but
uh unfortunately I'm a little skeptical
living in the world today watching
what's happening I'm sure they have
everything they need off the phone to
start with now you said a lot of things
there uh one uh you said you asked them
how they find you and yeah you said I'm
sure I know how they found me I I want
to say are you insinuating that the
phone and working with an apple or
whoever the phone company is they
located you that way is that is that
kind of what you're thinking
yeah that's exactly what I'm thinking
it's not like I announced to the world
hey I'm gonna be at this address out of
town on this day you know we live in a
dangerous world I got young children
that I'm trying to shield from you know
the rampant crime running across America
right now courtesy of the leftist
Democrats so I don't announce those kind
of things I tell people after the fact
hey I was just at so and so this is what
you know but it's after the fact uh and
so obviously look we're glad that they
can go after terrorists and criminals
and use technology to do that
unfortunately this is now the new
surveillance state where parents who
have the gall to go to a school board
meeting a school that they pay for in
their taxes right under penalty of law
by the way and have the gall to question
what the school is teaching their
children you know the FBI and the
Department of Justice puts a threat tag
on them that's the world we live in
today now to follow up with that you
know are you Droid or are you app Apple
what what kind of a phone I I I've got
an iPhone okay so you got an iPhone I
remember you know when the whole San
Bernardino thing happened I don't know
if you remember yeah how much heat Tim
Cook got for not uh giving the
information and recent book that just
came out called after Steve meaning
after Steve Jobs uh they specifically
talked about how the government didn't
like Tim Cook because he was close with
Trump and he was close with both
presidents and they're like how is it
that you're going to be close to a guy
like that is going to listen this guy
calls I I deal with him so and uh Tim
Cook most people don't even know he was
a former Republican is what he was Tim
Cook growing up I know that's going to
sound strange but that's a completely
different conversation the other part of
it is so you know they said they're
going to bring the phone back I'm
assuming they haven't yet brought the
phone back
and how much after did they bring you
back how much how many days after did
they bring well they said it was going
to be a couple hours it was the length
of the whole day which quite honestly I
didn't believe a couple hours but why
say a couple hours this is going to take
all day I mean why not just be truthful
about it so how about this now now that
you experienced that have you uh changed
your approach and philosophy on how your
you know handling your phones because
you know most of the time a lot of
people have two phones you know
especially people in your kind of a
position you have to have two phones one
is going to be working personally has
has anything with your approach changed
uh quite honestly it hasn't uh look my
life's an open book I don't say anything
on the phone that I would say publicly
you know yeah I objected to the electors
and I explained to the world why I
called for investigations I called for
audits I explained why those positions
haven't changed what my concern so I'm
not concerned about what I've said on my
phone what I've said I can't control
what other people send me number one
number two I absolutely can't control
what the FBI the Department of Justice
the CIA the NSA any of those three
letter alphabet organizations will put
on my phone I can't control that and
neither can anybody else yeah that's not
comfortable for me because I it's no
more it's not it's no one's business to
see what I'm telling my wife my kids my
that part there is zero I am zero
tolerance for that now let me ask you
what happens if you don't give the
phones let's just say the FDI FBI does
show me like I'm not giving it to you
what would they do to you
I I think they would turn you around put
you in handcuffs and haul you away I
mean look that's the new police state
that we live in understand on this phone
is attorney-client privilege I asked
them I said look if you wanted the phone
why don't you just contact my attorneys
you know I have attorneys now because of
this whole j6 charade right this this
so-called committee and the one agent
said oh you have so and so and so and so
is your attorneys I said yeah why don't
you just call them no answer to that
um so
again this is this is the world that we
live in and
um I I I you just gotta live that way
knowing that at any moment this could
look there after me at this moment there
after Mike Lindell Donald Trump John
Eastman Jeffrey Clark you name it the
list is long and distinguished but
that's us today it's going to be
everybody else and it just it's hired 87
000 or paid to hire 87 000 IRS agents do
you think they're going after you know
uh the guy that owns uh Amazon Jefferson
do you think they're going yeah they're
going not going after Mark Zuckerberg
they're coming after people that pay
some guy 25 bucks to cut the lawn you
know some lady that's trying to work
three jobs to pay for gas food and uh
the cost of living right now who who
then said well I'm not at home so I'm
going to hire somebody for you know 20
bucks to clean the house you know that's
who they're coming for so it's me today
it's you tomorrow so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]